lahter with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter
old wide now the coronavirus taking a
devastating toll confirmed cases now top
300,000 over 13,000 have died Elizabeth
Palmer is in London tonight tracking the
crisis
Korona babies believe it or not that's
Florida's governor David P alligator he
issued an executive order - see you
later alligator hi Jimmy I hope you and
your friends your family are as well as
can be expected of our new
post-apocalyptic world they're watching
the very special social
[Music]
[Music]
such a La Crosse phone for a teen that
in law
you can watch our show so luck
it's
make that
[Music]
can't see the ties are at the door no
toilet paper in the store passes along
14 do you think you're gonna face
realities in the police
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh very glad to be with you this is
called the I can't really swing my arms
for a proper a proper gait for me
because my shirts too small but you can
see it's an XL so for people to thing I
deliberately wear short shirts I find XL
strips it tilts on you yeah it's more
pre-emptive we have a big show for you
today big months coming up so first let
me cliff we have day he'd the nagua
on the show irish gamer 6 million
subscribers i don't know how to
pronounce his name but hopefully he's
okay and yes as you saw there um I
noticed all the late night host well
first let me introduce everybody Stu is
here stood as America yes is there a
specific percentage of Asian I need to
be to sit here not so much no honestly I
didn't really haven't done a 23andme um
there's like we have Bulldog his mom
spent a lot of time in the life food
markets quarter black Garrett is he
audio way the G Morgan Jr how are you
what's one of the day doing well I had
to look it's peju Cabernet it's what
paid you pay Jeju Hey paid you PJ I've
noticed that the late-night host they're
all broadcasting from their bathtub and
apparently NBC doesn't have the budget
for a lavalier microphone right it
Stephen Colbert Jimmy Kimmel's Samantha
B Trevor Noah everyone's gone
we've decided they're acceptable risks
unacceptable risks here atlatl Crowder
and there is going to be it's going to
be hashtag mug club quarantine if you
enter the promo code quarantine you'll
get $30 off the entire month of April
starting next Monday
everything that's usually available
exclusively at Mudd Club the blaze all
of this program will be available on
YouTube as well as three more shows yeah
morning drive show good morning mug Club
so every unite that is it 9:00 p.m.
Eastern Time Monday through Thursday and
then Monday Wednesday Friday at 9 p.m.
p.m. Eastern and in the morning 9:00 in
the morning
you guys can live-chat if you are of
course mug Club members you'll be able
to chat will be doing giveaways I don't
think a relief check because my wife and
I have the gall I believe to make over
$75,000 a year john deere yucks so we're
still gonna give away some money sir
guns will give away a lot of stuff no
idea is it wrong that a minute ago when
you say Samantha bees gone that I got
excited yeah it is wrong that's wrong
that you can have something more to say
about that that was like a punchline but
it's just - it's just me yeah half-asian
belt will be here for my club month he
just he can't be here right now better
lock down right and the Czar's of course
yeah which is the most sad about that I
can't make SARS jokes anymore
that's lapse now it has to be corona
virus and that's more sad than funny so
also a good time this month subscribe to
try to bits we're gonna have a lot of
content going up there on YouTube also
going up on Apple podcasts Android ever
so a lot of content we know that you
guys are kind of quarantine getting a
little stir-crazy and we don't want you
to feel like you're alone go to a lot of
credit I come /schedule where you can
see the schedule for the whole month we
really do appreciate it
not a doctor so this is how we can give
back this ice fire ya know when I hear
fight fire with fire I didn't have a
like why not water that controlled burn
so it just shows you don't call me call
the fire department if you have a little
bit of a tickle call an ambulance
if you want to watch so you know
juvenile jokes we are going to be
talking a whole lot day he'd and Nagas
will be on the show we'll be talking
about how the corona virus has handed
the twenty20 election to Donald Trump
those brings me to my question of the
day how do you think it'll affect the
2020 election do you think it's makes
President Trump more likely less likely
to win reelection and do you think the
daily televised press conferences have
helped or hurt spoiler alert CNN Rachel
Maddow and everyone who left thinks that
it actually helps them so they want to
start broadcasting it because all the
bad information out there we do want to
do our part be responsible you should
trust the medical professionals at the
CDC guys gonna put our cancerous anima
every sodomize but ou will get cancer in
the butthole God's gonna have a flame
coming out of your butthole
you're going to have a
playing coming out of here what hole if
you thought that ace was bad you ain't
seen nothing yet
and there'll be people walking around
all of America with flames coming out of
there but oh yeah we shouldn't be
walking around anywhere yeah with the
lockdown
well Gary home out of your butthole his
area of specialty maybe proctology
understand the geographical equation we
don't what's the rise by the way
self-quarantine it's not that awesome
[Laughter]
Glenn Beck
so with the rise of the self quarantine
you know people live been playing a lot
to a lot of board games at all this is
letting people in a pass at a time you
know Tom Hanks here's one thing as a
white man and I get I don't want to get
in the idea of identity politics it's
it's easy to forget that some folks
don't feel represented yeah in board
game so it's it is nice to see some of
the toy companies have been stepping up
to be more inclusive
[Music]
Rock'em Sock'em rabbis oh boy
Rock'em Sock'em rabbis Oh brytny Kippur
press the buttons move the joystick
thingies NUCCA skipper to the floor
you're the winner it's just like me best
two out of three dad you're my best
friend Rock'em Sock'em rabbis by Milton
Brett's melon brats and stepping up to
the they do control big board game to my
friend Ben Shapiro and Jeremy at the
daily wear something adds this
borderline Jeremy boring set me back a
gift laughing his ass off there you go
nothing not a peep from Ben forgiveness
afterwards does seem like board games
when you're just handing dice back and
forth to each other in a quarantine
situation is not ideal
right double the blow on the dice right
here or rub them on your taint does help
oh yeah Vegas they can't stop you they
say the casinos cannot stop so finally
fast food and not final we have a lot of
wishful thinking fast food chain you
know chick-fil-a they've been closing
their dining rooms allowing takeout and
drive through only delivery orders to
combat the spread so good for them but
not to be outdone Taco Bell has
announced that their tacos will now
contain 14 percent less bat meat is good
14% less but it gives it a little taste
is it you might think that 14 percent
seems arbitrary they've done their cost
analysis they have yes ratios they can
only afford two for 10% international
news use don't do as much international
news over there know if you do not have
it's just it's America it's America for
America America
you shop internationally Charles he
tested positive for the corona virus so
you know can't catch a break I think we
have us from CNN and someone over 70 the
Duke of Edinburgh is considered to be at
higher risk than average for coronavirus
up see dogs can be carriers and I know
it seems it seems like a cheap shot but
I took it that's what it is
come on Princess Diana I agree
next to princess diancie I'm especially
look more like a horse you think a dog
yeah it was like a dog horse I just I
thought she looked like that Afghan
breed of dog okay but I could see are we
talking like a radiator town Clydesdale
yeah I don't know that's a good question
III not a fast horse I feel I go says
smoosh that's a slow horse so probably
Clydesdale area like a [ __ ] oh yeah
oh wait no yes I do we weren't
demonetized with flagging butthole do we
find out here if Queen Elizabeth is
immortal now no is it like the blood of
the incestuous keeps you young
first you episodes were great third
third one not so much
despite by the way another Mohammed's
saying that all of your diseases in the
Quran that your all of your diseases
will be healed if you go to Medina the
cities of Mecca and Medina are nearly
empty right now so people are not making
their pilgrimage there there there are
no men in Mecca so you know what that
means it's ladies night so get your get
your beatings on the beach the fear in
her eyes beautiful fear that was like
nice you were into that I like that yeah
fear in her must present valid
identification six and older by the way
what are they going to not sleep with
six-year-olds
what if they want to sorry you're gonna
have to by the way put your home in a
blind trust okay it's a fun process and
we actually have two non coronavirus
stories because I know a lot of you and
to be clear do with the the mug Club
quarantine the month we're doing some
live chat with you guys we will still do
a Thursday show Tuesdays similar to the
transition but we don't a lot more
conversational shows live video game
streaming so it feels a little more
relaxed right now you know we can't do
this 9 times a week we can but I'd kill
myself and then then we could who are
you paying Stu yeah no definitely so we
have to nine coronavirus stories um in
China an army of 100,000 ducks have been
recruited to fight off a plague of
locusts Wow so another plague over there
this according to my favorite news
source the book of Revelation where the
four quack men yeah Bobby's question
here who kills the ducks when this is
over I'm gonna need an army of tigers to
kill the duck they're gonna eat them you
will hear the whales across the sea
locusts actually wouldn't feel bad from
Canadian geese they are there thee there
that our Jersey earth they poop in the
attack days - ah there's only two modes
cope mode and attack have you been I've
been attacked by Canadian goose leg Oh
three times really I mean physical
contact three times yeah really well I
mean I just ran away like a register
pain the same way we do Yeah right they
they don't know they don't care no I
like his story where I was actually bit
by a bat as a child what yes so you're
the reason like who Hans do that's me
but it's a truck I'm gonna stick ready
my parents came out and saw there was a
bat like I guess I must have knocked it
or something it was it was right next to
us and I had a bite mark on my stomach
it's a little kids what do you mean you
guess you might have knocked it was
before hanging up in the ceiling upside
down there's no accidental bad knocking
what well they came dice swooped at me
or something okay and I used my reflexes
my childlike reflexes yeah I was able to
knock down the bat the bat somehow
struggled to its feet walked over took a
bite out of my stomach and then we have
the corona virus this is like the bat
just never goes down ready for another
story hard sell to brand white claw have
released three new flavors lemon
watermelon and tangerine most excited
about this news drunk you know like the
white club I'm all in on the white cloth
Wow I don't care I have no I don't I
don't try I never said I was a masculine
guy
I never even been so well feast you
right up until the last two segments we
have until the last two really cuz I was
I think you're doing fine
really yeah don't take from him the bad
guy he's a drunk I think I see that he's
always drunk he's always drinking wine
but he says for some reason if you're
drunk on wine all the time connoisseur
sorry I don't have culture I don't have
manliness I have none of those things
I'm an essential worker okay guys sorry
yeah that was actually with the scene
no let's keep going we do film opens
Johnny boy mike-mike an ad and a friend
you said hey how about a parody of this
scene it was the sense of her cause I'm
like from Schindler's List before they
what are you thinking
this happened this week that and then I
love him dearly
even Brendan but he said hey can my
family come in this to watch the show
and I said what they're there they're
nine states away he's we have it they
you know they would plan a vacation as
well the tickets are refundable right
now it's another driving loading up the
car to New York on September 12 2001
there couldn't be a worse time for
travel terrible idea he's really happy
no they live in a rural area but they're
staying at got this Hacienda courts and
every Valero station touch on the gas
pump no so he's working from home he's
been since fired finally before we'll
get I do want to hear from you guys if
you think that 2020 has changed with the
coronavirus I think this actually has
since Simpson for Donald Trump but
before we get to that finally San
Francisco obviously you know that it's
been completely shut down in response to
the corona virus pandemic residents
they're being ordered complete shelter
in place to stay in their homes it's one
of the strictest protocols across the
country San Franciscans of course
responded with but where will we it's a
try the corner by product a patriarchy
genetically yeah goals people don't talk
about that enough they don't they don't
because of the quarantine no this is to
San Francisco there's been a huge uptick
in you should like this quarter black
here it will be doing in free mud club
monitoring the promo codes quarantine
$30 off everyone gets a student in
military pricing video games will be
video game streaming they're much more
popular now in San Francisco than a huge
uptick some of the titles actually might
surprise you which brings us to this
week's seven plus one
just so you know yeah we are doing 7+1
and still if Glen fires you there is no
home for you here okay
consider me the tiger to your Fred
Flintstone putting you out of the house
oh no way you're getting it this is
seven plus one of the most popular video
games in San Francisco amidst the
coronavirus crisis so number seven
popular game a Champions call right now
is Call of Duty so that's yeah that
makes kids love that one it's a
multiplayer okay yeah how about you take
number six number six resident needles
yeah that's a big one resident needles
in San Francisco it's pretty popular
this actually is fun because it's an
open world but it's not without hope one
of ones is number five grand theft auto
immune deficiency audio give us number
four because I don't want all the
liability number four angry turds
you can see it's angry and look at
something Golden Gate Bridge into
something so silly that could have been
time put into research
number three popular game in again
coronavirus quarantine in San Francisco
number three mortal kombat meet
so that's Raiden was played by a white
guy yep totally white not true anytime
you put on the rice paddy hat just make
sure they're actually aged yeah yeah
please they didn't get the memo no
number two Gerald G Morgan Jr remember
Final Fantasy 19 homosexual curfew hours
look at that they never stop with the
Final Fantasy no there are so many never
final really matter and the number one
most popular video game in San Francisco
right now missed the corona quarantine
Metal Gear Solid stool so yeah
try not to make sounds but is but all we
making all pans of fire is sound to be
clear he's not actually from the CDC and
the plus one most popular video game
title right now in San Francisco Super
Smash Brothers which really is yeah just
a placeholder so that always forget and
we will be reading at some of your live
chat next week 9 p.m. Central 10 p.m.
Eastern Monday morning our first morning
show so you can only you can only do the
live chat though at blaze we're not
doing it on you tuning right we don't
want to give YouTube money 9 a.m. I am
not peeing I am what I say p.m. 8 p.m.
we're doing p.m. as well I'm doing so
many so many shows I can't stop what the
shows gotcha there's so many shows we
are the best people they always say I do
too many shows I say no I can do more
but I get but they say you give so much
and I just I just get so much now I do
this is I think what do you think Stu
before you into this do you think this
is helped Donald Trump or hurt Donald
Trump well it's still yet to be seen
right if this turns into zombie
apocalypse it's probably not gonna get
elected but maybe nobody if he can come
to the point where he looks competent
through this especially if this thing
bounces back it's gonna be he's gonna
have some smooth sailing yeah yeah yeah
I think yeah I think he's I think it's
going to go pretty well I think this
actually has already seems 2d let me
kind of make some points as to why and
you guys can let me know where you think
I'm wrong yeah you can let me know as
you very often do the media's been
trying to claim that he's been terrible
at his job okay but Donald Trump's
overall approval rating and by the way
this is where polls matter not like when
Bernie Sanders says look at Venice look
at the news will they prefer their
health care so they do in Cuba a
different deal but they die so they
prefer it up until the moment where you
know they die so that's no and by the
way we'll be talking with Dan Uggla who
had an operation on his hideous
testicles scrotum and testicles
operation I'm back just bro streets this
isn't that they put it back
we've said don't use reusable bags
because they transmit disease is a it's
almost like that's why we had plastic
bags and straws you [ __ ] I love how all
that stuff this goes right out the
window and I was a serious who doesn't
want a straw right now were we not told
that the you know the whole environment
was the biggest threat right there I
guess you read it as soon as something
else happens they all abandon it yeah
yeah but also the same you know the same
sort of eddy Haskell's it's still China
it comes to climate change and there's
still China yeah now when it comes to
viruses still China pattern China a lot
of it I mean I don't want to vilify an
entire nation of people but Jen is a
horrible place so not the people but the
government again let's be really I hope
those people are liberated eventually
from this government nice shame to me
that the media is carrying the water for
the Chinese propagandist government
those you want to know who's not a fan
of Jake Tapper all the Chinese who don't
work for the government
yeah so this is where polls matter
because Donald Trump emits a crisis and
this is kind of important because you
see this quite a bit historically it's a
good indicator 60% of Americans actually
approve of his response he's a
coronavirus his recent approval rating
with a Gallup risen from 44 to 49
percent yeah Wow right who Americans
rate the worst right now by the way the
the fake fake lying news media that's
what they rate as the worst aspect of
American culture second worse is late
night hosts broadcasting from their
bathroom without a lavalier mic that's
up there we get it it's raw it's organic
Samantha bee and Jimmy Kimmel but can't
you just take a portion of the 12
million salary and just get a rogue mic
you were wearing a suit in a bathtub so
do that just this is and this is also by
the way why why they want to lean on
YouTube right Vox NBC Universal they
realize they can't compete when they
start putting this content no one wants
to watch Seth Meyers in his hallway not
more than once at the very least yeah
well you gotta Lily singing yeah because
Trump's approval rating for Democrats
just overall is 13% right super low he
had 29 percent approval from Democrats
on his handling of coronavirus Wow over
twice the amount of Democrats approve of
his handling than just generally like
him
that is ICU that's a big
I wonder why that is how much do you
think of this is just rallying around
the president in a crisis any I don't
think that because the media has been
attacking him nuns yeah so I mean you
could say maybe maybe people just are
tired of seeing someone getting you know
pummeled by the bullying media at some
point fighting back it'll be different
for example with Barack Obama and there
was you know there was obviously the the
recession or right after 9/11 these
people didn't have such mistrust for the
media where's at this point they're very
open in their attacks on them so I I
don't know I don't know it's it's a good
question you guys let us know but I do
have some other points that I think will
hopefully build the case that that
hopefully that's not the case um here's
a point okay so travel bands to answer
your question that's - I don't know that
President Trump has done a whole lot
differently than any other president
would I think there's a limited amount
of control that you have the CDC doesn't
really have anything necessarily to do
with Trump they sort of operate
independently and we didn't have the
right information from China the World
Health Organization did not declare it a
crisis or a pandemic until March 12th so
I to be clear I know everyone's trying
to score political points I can't say
that Donald Trump has done everything
right or differently than another
president but Johnny boy who had the
horrible idea of the Schindler's List
parody you know one thing that President
Trump has specifically done differently
than all other leaders and that's his
travel ban from China was big Donald
Trump banned it early they didn't do
that elsewhere at the same they didn't
go with the same vigor you should say
and we can compare that directly with
his competitor in a general election
Joe dementia Biden who claimed that the
travel ban was xenophobic so this is
remarkable to me even if everything else
from President Trump were terrible was
absolutely let's say he handled
everything as poorly as can be he's
still not as bad as Joe Biden they put
up someone in the general if I'm Donald
Trump and I go into this general
election is the debate with Joe Biden
yet heightened eases or was enough of a
response
I just coach Donald Trump say all right
let it fly well listen i put the bin and
travel from china you said it was racist
so wet when would you put travel
restrictions on china Joe and he won't
be able to answer probably now you know
and forget where he is for a little bit
you know Matt he's back-to-back
competitors so far are gonna be Hillary
Clinton and Joe Biden like the two right
weakest people to put up against anyone
yeah well especially though on the
coronavirus another word
they he has no leg to stand on on what
will be the hot-button issue here
absolutely if you were just some random
recession or something that happened
they could try and attribute it to
policy right right it was this it's
clear as day Donald Trump did something
proactive you accuse him of racism by
the way Biden was just following
lockstep with the media they claimed it
was nonsensical an emotional reaction
this is from fox new york times they
also said that we shouldn't really worry
about the coronavirus that was less than
the flu but now interact like that's
just a right wing talking point we got
it from you one of italy's wasn't one of
italy's a-- virality yeah he said when
in responding the outbreak that the fear
of the political fallout from enacting a
travel ban made the pandemic much worse
in italy this is what he said now the
american media was saying no no don't
listen to that guy who works in italian
government it has nothing to do with
open borders yeah exactly in the entire
EU was pissed because donald trump said
we're handling this better than the EU
we actually put a travel ban in before
the EU and it was like well we put our
travel ban in for four days earlier and
it didn't help us so now they're all
pissed off about that it's like actually
this works this does help stop it didn't
help you but it is helping italy only
put a travel ban in from china yeah the
rest of the borders were effectively
opens yeah we are at a point where
political correctness could quite
literally be killing people LGBTQA i and
people died that's the point here hands
up don't shoot i don't mean no that's
this is an actual thing you don't ban
travel from china where the virus
originated people will die yeah and you
go back to like our definition of
political correctness is different than
the original right the original is from
marxist states where and and this is
very specific where the chinese
government they decided the politically
correct thing for doctors to do is deny
that there was a virus yeah so this is
legitimately this entire thing is
actually an extension of political
correctness right yeah and it's
dangerous it's not without consequences
people think it's well i'm being nice
because i'm not offending people and
we'll get to that in a second yeah we
talked about this too going back to your
point in the EU it's great that we have
a defensible border right now it's great
that we have a border that we can
control to some degree the EU wishes
they had that right
yeah because people can just come in and
go wherever they want like you said a
travel ban is only effective if it's
everybody coming to your country for a
China period and it's not the only thing
there's been obviously a multi-faceted
approach from quarters Donald Trump if
this is one thing that you can say
singularly unique in comparison to
whether it's Biden or Bernie but it
seems like the candidate will obviously
be Biden unless you know they don't have
enough smelling salts but the point is I
think that's a that's a stark contrast
coulda said Joe Biden is really unwell
he is not doing well at all this this
week he had a series of disastrous media
appearances first I think we have this
the one with a failed teleprompter on a
live stream watch said beefed up the
number of responders dealing with the
crush these crushing cases and we are
well let me let me go the second thing
President must use a defense production
Act
the second thing no Joe what's the
second thing what I stopped and motion
there he looks like he's checking
someone for testicular cancer you have
to be putting him out there in that
combine no really I'm asking seriously
it's not a punchline no you just didn't
have someone waving it off like stop but
now Joe Biden's me stupidest having
watched him we should be concerned about
is the Biden itis it looks like you know
iam Rocky I think was rocky for right
Apollo Creed is in there fighting Robin
Drago oh yeah and then right there he's
got the towel he's right throw in the
towel and he doesn't throw it in right
cost Apollo his life right that's what
his family needs to be there with a
towel and throw the towel it's over for
John it's very fitting because Putin
will kill him
break it symbolism is everywhere
they won't do the fist bump though
because six feet we understand that so
he then went on the view and the
responses they weren't they were not at
all coherent in hot topics we just about
Trump saying the government would
reassess the recommended period for
keeping businesses shut and people at
home are you at all concerned as Trump
said that we cannot let the Cure be
worse than the problem itself we have to
take care of the cure that will make the
problem worse no matter what I don't
want to be that guy of the gotcha in his
defender he didn't misspeak
see I get it all I thought I was taking
care of the Smiths right there almost
perhaps Joy Division this very sad lady
to throw in the towel so let's get back
to coronavirus cuz that's what we care
about right now the Democrats offices
have been blocking you know the relief
bill was a stimulus bill they blocked
the bill from the GOP so Minister
earlier on with I think was it 1400
pages this bill do we know how many
pages Internet keeps changing by the day
they came with you have to pass it yeah
then you can for you good really very
counter I think had 14-under pain and it
contained all sorts of ridiculous crap
that had nothing to do with the
coronavirus I'm sure you've heard of
this if you haven't there's thirty five
million in funding for the JFK
Performing Arts Center ninety million
for an HIV program three hundred million
for migration and Refugee assistance
green new deals these style requirements
for carbon emissions listen over 3.2
million Americans just filed for
unemployment okay and the Democrats are
demanding 300 million for illegal
immigrants and refugees yeah you wonder
why America the Heartland doesn't think
that you have their best interests at
heart because a nutless monkey would be
more effective at putting America and
one of the things isn't in the bill here
that just came out Ted Cruz was talking
about this I think yesterday saying you
just raised unemployment benefits from
around $11 an hour which is not enough
money for you to sit at home and just
collect a paycheck right 227 ish dollars
per hour that's what they raised it to
about 1100 just over a thousand dollars
a week right you can make it around
$48,000 a year sitting and doing nothing
yeah somebody's crazy amazing it's
you're giving them terrible incentives
here oh no and you look at this and this
is just basically today 3.2 million
unemployed is it's a trailer for the
movie of a Bernie Sanders or Joe Biden
president right we're all seeing a
preview of it today it's not fun yet
when people say oh this present we need
a socialized health care program
really how'd the CDC you yeah exactly
how do they work it out how'd it go in
Italy where right now if you're over 60
you don't get a ventilator because
they're just rationing larsson you're on
your own yeah okay we have other company
on why are we getting testing kits in
more Matt we're getting more testing
kits because of private labs everything
out we talked about that with dr. Troy
we're getting more masks
the origin Jaakko they're gonna be
sending us some masks they're making
masks right now 3m is it Haynes
Honeywell the private sector has stepped
up and they are the ones who are helping
Americans fixing the CDC's craphole yeah
does the CDC is the closest thing we
have to a single-payer program here
right and South Korea who's getting all
the praise they just embraced the free
market faster right their government
made a decision to go to the private
market and has worked they did that and
I also kind of Doc's they're citizens so
that wasn't it hand over your
geo-tagging and post it for public to
avoid Stephen also if we're all were
just a monolith racially because it's
different people are fun diseases a
little bit differently it's more
predictable yeah not saying it because
oh saying it because it is not nearly as
diverse as the United States and it's
tough to control a virus we have it
different we have all different kinds of
ages we have all we probably have more
genders in South Korea now I'm sure
about that pansexual the molecular on a
molecular biology level how they respond
to the corona virus a pandemic I would
pay a nickel to see that cellular Simbu
symbiosis in a petri dish I trust Joe
Biden's teleprompter more than I trust
the DMC the United States right now
there are a lot of things that I trust
more than the danson namely all of them
here's another thing this was a big deal
and it may seem inconsequential but I
think to go back to your point I think
this is why Americans think that Donald
Trump is doing a better job handling
this and they if it were just in a
vacuum Donald Trump oh we approve her
rallying around the leader that wouldn't
explain the distrust of the media yeah
that tells me there's a conflict that
tells me that to most Americans
including Democrats there's kind of a
hero and a villain here yeah and a big
part of that was of course if you
haven't been following it and we have
the Chinese virus controversy we
continued our relentless effort to
defeat the Chinese virus
this is just another no it comes from
China that's why each other you know
China tried to say at one point maybe
this stuff now that it was caused by
American soldiers that can't happen it's
not gonna happen not as long as I'm
president
it comes from China seeing some
important developments in our war
against the Chinese virus
[Laughter]
Jetta if you're gonna fix a problem you
need to speak truth yes you need to
write an obvious kated between behind
this all this political correctness and
you have to speak truth and what it is
it came from China that's working it yes
it matter why is Trump saying Chinese
virus valuable it's not just because it
offends all the right people for the
same reason that bonus instituting a
travel ban from China was valuable for
the same reason that trumps brass
pendulous sack in comparison not the
Biden's shriveled DeMint and Raisinets
is valuable he's not allowing political
correctness to dictate policy best for
Americans also I'll tell you why
Chinese virus is important and you see
this a lot with all of these right and
you see it even in the Christian
community you know that's committed that
the virtue sin link me like we should be
nice don't know you know why Chinese
virus is important because a communist
regime who tried to blame this virus on
our American troops doesn't get to
rewrite history
by the way sign up for a mug love this
month the promo code is quarantine we're
giving away everything plus three
morning shows you know $69 you get $30
off hit the notification bell if you're
on youtube and you are not subscribed
yet because subscriptions don't mean a
whole lot and yeah also crowd a bit
subscribe and hey look it looks to
string from his mug go to him see he
can't talk turned it around
to go back to the point of the media
this is something that's really
important to me I don't know how how
more clearly we could see the media
overreach right now when they start
blank blaming Donald Trump for people
eating koi pond cleaner when I saw the
story I was like no they're not they're
not gonna jump on this ya know there's
no way that they lack the self-awareness
to blame Donald Trump right for
simpletons for Mongoloids drinking koi
pond cleaner mmm yeah
I love it it shows who they are we've
had a hard time getting people to
sometimes understand on the left that
hey look the media is really biased like
you're living in that bubble apparently
this is showing very clearly like we're
not making this up I'm not just saying
that Trump's always right he's not when
he's wrong we have to call him out right
we hold him to account but look what
they're doing some lady murdered her
husband essentially rights employed
today we thought I'd chloric will it or
whatever was like it in the korklan
whatever bill what do you what kalasa
Pam is that wine bottle did Yuri cork
that I know you say this in the court
but let me just give you a rapid-fire
recap as to all of their all of the
dishonest is here so somebody probably
heard Trump disbanded the pandemic the
pandemic unit there at the the CT was at
CDC or the White House NHS yeah actually
he just can just condensed it with other
units that the expertise could be pulled
was actually decision to make government
more effective and efficient not desi
they try to say that Trump cut CDC
funding reducing the outreach by one of
it from 49 countries to 10 including
cutting their work in China the truth is
it wasn't a direct cut it was a
depletion of previously allocated funds
and the CDC got that money from
elsewhere so it's a wash who cares and
the media tried to say that Trump of
course called the coronavirus a hoax no
what do you say what the Democrats
pinning the blame on his administration
was a hoax and of course don't forget
the fish tank cleaner but we all
understand that one that one's really
stupid it's fun to address but I don't
want to go over it here's the deal after
years years of the anti-trump net the
Russian collusion the you Cannes quid
pro quo can the general public can how
can they trust the media at all if you
never heard them say one good thing
about President Trump and now they're
saying he's handling the outbreak poorly
when in fact it was the New York Times
the media who downplayed it was
but you said there were prostitutes
peeing on the Formica you said is
incorrect why would they trust you now
right what do you think he's this thing
it's rallying behind I do think that I
think this is a good case here I mean
and you see this occasionally from media
members when they actually will
acknowledge something the daily that New
York Times podcast which is basically 30
minutes of them destroying Trump every
day in their minds no I don't yeah i so
i with my compromised immune system
that's BC I'm susceptible to ear a yeah
they had Maggie Haberman on who was kind
of flipped and like Gyllenhaal's ugly
sister yes exactly and shows up in a sit
on the big screen I make an audible I
think so she said she admitted she said
you know what early on in this situation
Trump banned flights from China he was
called racist he was called xenophobic
and it turned out that it was a good
move and it was a big move at the time
yeah now they they wrapped that in 30
minutes of criticism but at least if
they will acknowledge basic truths it'll
at least give us a chance to understand
and listen to the criticism right
they're so unwilling because they're so
obsessed with this guy yeah then you
won't normally won't even give him a
point into his favor no matter what
happens right yeah I think it's a real
problem by the way um this is something
to they complain about the Republican
bill we've heard about this guy go back
and forth all week we'll talk about it
more next week like the morning show
will be watching CNN lie fact-checking
so it'll be a little different guests
it'll be more like a podcast radio show
less late night II I guess so we'll be
able to talk more in depth about the
bill but initially the left's complain
that the Republican bill would allow
hospitals this was a big thing that they
would allow elective procedures to be
put on hold to make room for corona
patients that included abortions right
so here's the deal both sides have
accused the other side of playing
politics with this bill you're trying to
fit this in and you're trying to earmark
this okay all right and let's assume
that that is true because it is true
both sides are trying to play a little
bit of political football right right
now they're trying to shoehorn their
crap in all right let's assume all of
that is true what would be more relevant
to a bill exclusively designed to curb
the coronavirus and hopefully its
economic ripple effect and devastation
helping hospitals alleviate their
workload
by holding all non-essential procedures
like abortions putting it on hold or as
the Democrats tried to shove into their
bill diversity quotas for corporate
boards you know Hospice getting
hospitals masks respirators are making
sure that there's a new being on
retainers advisor at delt and I think we
do have to go to the nagas here this is
something that's really important to
some people trying to make this case for
socialism I think if you actually
observe this objectively you'd have to
take this as a case against centralized
government our cousin the private sector
has stepped up and tried to fix a
quagmire that was created by government
regardless of who's in office but it
also shows us that you know what there
is a finite amount of resources with
government it's ironic to me that the
left they think well this person has
more and so I want to take it they don't
nursing the capitalism free enterprise
is not a zero-sum game that's not just a
piece of the pie
you can bake more pies you know what is
a fixed pie government there's only so
much money they can take especially if
everybody is unemployed for indefinitely
right there's a limited amount of
resources so let's take into account the
idea that the government they've had
this Russia hoax investigation going on
how many tens of millions when you add
that up in hundreds of millions but I
don't know billions all have the numbers
in front of me the impeachment sham
going on and the CDC how about the CDC
instead of researching gender pronouns
and gun control statistics you do your
job that way people want to take a
steaming crap on you as an emblem of a
systemic corruption and bureaucracy and
government looking to the private sector
for help there's a fixed amount of
resources and the government seems like
maybe we should be a little more prudent
in where we use our resources so that
we're not caught flat-footed with our
pants down again all right this guy the
Irish guy Dena glutton oddly do not know
done out I don't mention a Spanish
[Music]
unless madrugada spread caste Columbia
Noah nada Masada kokyo natasa the cafe
in the black rifle coffee own cigar
[Music]
coated black rifle coffee dot-com /
Crowder use promo code Crowder for 20%
off your first purchase
black rifle coffee dot-com / Crowder use
a promo code Crowder you get 20% off
your first order and you know what a lot
of sponsors have been dropping out right
now because of the economic downturn and
we understand that but not black rifle
they continue to support the show and
sponsors like like them and Walter are
the reason that we can provide mug Club
do the bug Club quarantine month for
free for everyone right now while you
guys are getting stir-crazy so it's
black rifle coffee calm / card or use a
promo code Crowder if you drink coffee
there's is legitimately better and they
have the tested Claussen to sponsor the
show look that bag is tough
what did I break it
[Music]
you know what you can do with them
dishes and if you ain't man enough to do
it for yourself I'd be happy to oblige
[Music]
you know what you can do with your
copyright strikes and if you ain't man
enough to do it yourself
I'd be happy to oblige the baddest we
Jeanette me
I really would going on the shows and
save all kind of things but I don't
from where I am sun is shining
and watch this and more at our other
channel Crowder bits anyone who don't
like it can get bone
[Music]
all right our next guest uh I'm pretty
glad have mine and he's moved heaven and
earth he has to be on the show it's true
because that's those are the names of
his right and left testicle now if we
think that's not just being dirty for
the sake of it he actually had a
procedure but we'll talk about that's
not the lead the lead is one of the most
popular gamers on all of the youtubes
that Joe Biden refers to at the tube or
also what so he doesn't want to give me
his full name because he thinks I'm
mispronouncing so you can search nagua
on YouTube but I'm gonna try it anyway
mr. Dyk the dougla was that even close
thank you for being on the show
Oh God okay all right he also was from
an earlier Guy Ritchie film just in case
you may speak to confirm LOX Nakia wait
he's only a character from snatch was
what I was getting it I love that how do
I say it it's Gaelic right yeah oh wow
so this is why I didn't say it before I
was like what is it typhi is it desi you
knew I wasn't even close
we're gonna make your lives easier
Barris myself no not the second part
okay Nagas that's all right you know
yeah but still you heard me say die
theme you could have said don't say it
because you'll sound like an idiot but
instead you reverse psychology to me
because you know I'm an idiot
that's a good job well good so listen so
right now if I'm not mistaken and people
again you can find just type in Dena
glad he's on Twitter he's on YouTube
does a lot of video gaming which we'll
talk about more on the web extended
because mug Club quarantine this whole
month we'll be doing some live video
game streaming you're stateside right
now correct yeah I'm in LA okay and so
you're already so familiar with it that
you use the abbreviations what brings
these losses what brings you to Los
Angeles and are you are you stranded can
you not get home now I wasn't planning
to go home so I'm fine I'm fine being
here
okay I'm but no I've been traveling back
and forth from Ireland LA I live in
then I traveled to LA frequently okay
and I've been doing that for about a few
years now few years now well what are
you doing in Los it because you do the
gaming thing something you do that from
anywhere I do the same thing I do the
same thing but I might meet more people
that are within the industry do deals
and stuff Network yada yada all right
right a lot boring business yes
hopefully when you do the deals you
don't say it that way like I thought
we'd do a deal yada yada
you know stuff you know so how long are
you planning on staying here for people
you've been on the show before but it's
been a long time yeah I was like two
years I was on the show or something
like that yeah and I did I was in
Ireland at the time now I hope to go
back to Ireland I know within two months
okay and that's seeming it's it's maybe
like that but right now I mean it's got
a coin flip
exactly it is a coin flip well actually
I think was the Irish authorities really
don't know they tracked write the first
case of the coronavirus we flew from a
man who was travelling was he was in
northern Italy and then yes and he came
into Dublin and then he went up the nan
nan and then he left again or something
like that and he was the first person
Lauren together yes and then I read some
of somewhere in the Irish press if they
were saying Donald Trump is blaming the
EU for needing to add Ireland to the
u.s. travel ban which doesn't seem have
you been following this I haven't
followed that specific path but I've
just I've seen stuff in news and social
media and whatnot but I wouldn't
consider myself an expert no I know none
of us are experts we're not doctors or
microbiologists yeah you play video
games and I tell jokes do you still a
family of course in Ireland I would
imagine yeah yeah to dogs there as well
but they're taking care of there okay
well they're not carriers so that's good
Alex can get it apparently really yeah a
virus oh my god feel sad know what I'm
not like a BuzzFeed out PETA will care
yeah they what what how would you say
they've been reacting there in Ireland
versus stateside of you been in
communication with your families or is
there big yeah I know I messaged him I
think it's about to Sam
mother bought me a giant fridge and
stuff too full of food right hand
freezer just stuff too full of food
pretty early on I actually flew out to
America like first week of March and
then it was pretty much like two weeks
later really excited you couldn't fly
right was four weeks after our four
weeks boat yeah but six weeks four weeks
after the surgery so I got really lucky
with how like everything panned out
right get to LA because I have my um I
have my girlfriend here so you know not
only across the country flight
indefinite period of time right right
plus you know you got to put a ring on
it if you want that visa I tell her I
don't need you for the visa it's not
like 90-day fiance and I'm just with you
for the green right you already have a
visa to be here yeah so you reverse
psychology to her as well I guess sort
of because some people stateside to have
been getting this wrong and I spend some
time in Ireland I don't frankly I don't
have much interest in going elsewhere in
Europe at this point because um I've had
official complaints with Twitter what is
it China Pakistan was it somewhere in
the UK for drawing Mohammed for people
here who don't necessarily understand
because obviously Italy we've talked
about this they didn't close their
borders for a long time sometimes people
don't realize that the United States no
it's bigger than a lot of areas when
we're talking to like the UK right or
even if you include the UK I mean I'm
trying to think of all even surrounding
countries the United States alone is
bigger and so we don't think of how
important those borders kind of are when
there are different countries in a
continent like Europe have you is this
something that you think might for
example have ramifications for brexit
now because people over there understand
that they need to be able to kind of
seal things up in a pandemic personally
I think you know humans are fairly slow
to change so I don't I think I'll have a
very little impact really politically in
terms of like how people perceive
borders there
we just boil it down to something else
right you know what I mean they'll find
something else that makes them not think
of a change that's necessary for future
right you know like ideally is it's so
long getting through borders anyway
these days
in your lines and whatnot how long I've
only done you know I've done Customs
going obviously to Ireland but I haven't
been raised in Canada I would go through
the Canadian United States borders and
sometimes that could be kind of lengthy
one time I got in trouble because I
bought a pair of shorts from Old Navy
American flag shorts and I didn't and I
was put in the back room for a while
what is going through borders right now
it's fairly simple it's fine it's very
simple
it's a bit awkward going to a country
that like they don't really speak your
language or anything like that sorry but
it's oh it's when you're explaining why
you're there but usually like it's just
I'm on a holiday and they're like yeah
come on in sound like a crack security
squad no no but you do have to line up
and talk to somebody and stuff like that
the ones that I would say that tougher
are like American immigration is you
have to like they have one in Shannon
and then they have one if you don't fly
from Shannon to us you have to meet
immigration in the u.s. yeah and yeah
they could be some of them can be real
hired asses and like if they don't
understand what you're saying and I have
to explain like my YouTube job yeah like
they're like you're drunk like I got an
alcoholic and for well I do wake it up
tired as well gone after 6:00 a.m.
flight so yeah you're probably right
yeah but yeah once I got my visa they
pretty much got very relaxed about like
right about it because like this visa
was pretty much like this guy's safe
yeah everything like that but before the
visa I when I was traveling on a Nesta
they were really like hard-ass about it
and like sometimes I was like standing
there like
might be going home here use happen with
my mom you know my mom I used to make
this joke she's french-canadian
so we would go through the border just
north of Plattsburgh in a place called
Champlain people out there if you know
from upstate New York know what I'm
talking about let me know it said
there's nothing there that's how cool
the United States was to Canadians I
don't know if he felt this one when you
came to to the States but we would go to
the States for like Taco Bell and gap
and things like that and we would always
go through to Plattsburgh high and my
mom would get nervous and my mom would
when my mom has a tendency she's
french-canadian when she gets nervous to
make other people nervous and so that's
just mom I've met other moms they're
amateurs say okay and citizens and my
dad would say all three American
citizens and one alien and my mom would
go
beep-beep and hold up four cards like
this and they'd say I don't like you at
all
and the french-canadian accent sounds
like a cartoon character to a lot of
people it doesn't sound like a real
accent so she was constantly questioned
I've got here's one thing I do want to
ask you because you had surgeries and
you were traveling well I don't know
this because they weren't necessarily
traveling certainly not internationally
it wasn't declared a pandemic I think
until March 12th so you traveled before
that were you really knows before that
yeah it there's before and were you
really scared because I remember I
traveled not long before it either and
it really wasn't even the in the air
people act like we all knew we certainly
don't when I was traveling domestically
did were you afraid or was it just kind
of off the radar well I was definitely
more cautious than normal so you know
brought hand sanitizer wipes right even
even then they were pretty much sold out
in Ireland back back early marriage oh
wow so yeah my motor stopped open that
as well the motors yeah
yes I'm thankfully in my second flight I
was on the first flight I just I was a
seat away from someone else and so I was
good and then my second flight my long
flight I was in the back right corner
and no I couldn't even see anyone from
where I was sitting and so basically
yeah I was I was never really near
anyone right and so I think I made it
easier on my mind yeah like it was no
I'm coughing right next to me basically
right white imagine made it easier in
your mind and then that which brings me
to my next point
how are your balls so for people that
don't know you had a recent surgery to
quote you in your video you said maybe I
hope I'm not blown the lid off because
you didn't speak out of publicly no no
no they unbagged your groceries you said
that's what you said I think in your
video no I'm just can't blow into myself
what was the procedure exactly I saw it
was a Hydra super pair it's fairly rare
like one of you guys could have it and
you wouldn't even know it
what with other health issues right now
I'm just learning to wash my hands
properly I have to sing happy birthday
twice and watch your balls yeah but I
don't sing I don't sing happy birthday
when I wash my balls I sing call on me
from Chicago the techno remix because it
seems appropriate so I've served my
purpose hydrogen repair basically and
there's like this little kind of tube
that goes down into your testes and
around that is like this skin thing of
that there's like you know your grind
I'm imagining it now the grafts yeah you
know and then basically imagine like
something like just hold something hole
opened up don't know how they don't even
know how it happens they think it's
information from they don't actually
know and
imagine like a small drip of liquid jizz
coming down through that like several
years oh so yeah like for me it's weird
having balls that are normal-sized
because I don't remember when they were
normal like so you're just bragging it
gets bowls you've ever seen and like you
know I've got normal balls apparently
they were normal like five years ago
because one time when I was going up the
stairs you have like boxers that are you
know bit showing I have sides I was
going up the stairs and my brother was
saying goodnight to me or something like
that and he looked up in sama balls and
he said he said he remembers that
forever told me there were normal day
[Music]
it's about five years of fluid building
up and it was about the size of it it
was a pair in the left side it was like
the right one was fine it was just
shoved out it was like if you're sitting
next to a fat person in a cinema
scenario are your balls the fat person
no yes my left the right one was a
normal person okay all right so the
Levin Smith and the right ball is
whoever is unfortunate enough to sit
next to Kevin Smith size of a pair and
then I was like okay
I wonder what back down and I got a card
and stuff like that and they put some
fluid on it Ultra sounded like yeah
that's a Hydra seal check me in for his
surgery I got actually really quick yeah
it for private I paid out of cash well
you didn't go with you didn't go with
the universal health care there in
Ireland no no my dad has been on a
waiting list I think for about two years
first of surgery or something like that
for his mullet just his balls okay
you're okay
I haven't seen him don't know but
something else with him okay it's like a
reoccurring I think it might be ulcers
or whatever but our kidney stones or
something like that two years for kidney
stones because my mom in Canada was a
year and I think was a year and three
months Herman it might've been 14 months
and some change for an MRI when she
ruptured a disc in her lower back and
Americans can't believe that when I say
it but it sounds like it's pretty
comparable in Ireland for a lot of these
things yeah well I think it's two years
because I remember being a [ __ ] mom at
the kitchen table whatever I was like
hey let me let me pay for your you know
your operation you can get it done
probably in a few weeks or something
like that just Petra private yeah I mean
he's just he's just like no like if I
it's fine
you know he's like I pay my taxes and
they said they're gonna do this so I'm
gonna make him do it right so like he's
kind of like they work for me mentality
in two years they're gonna hear from in
two years they'll never hear the end
well you know I wouldn't I goes that
have they contacted you back and they're
like no what they said to do it and they
give me let her send it doing yeah I
like to know what he gosh I don't know
what he got you know how long is up in
the case in Ireland because when I was
raised in Canada we weren't allowed to
have any privatized insurance and then
they opened it up because so many they
declared it actually there's a Supreme
Court case declared it a violation of
Human Rights because people were willing
to pay for care right in these scenarios
and they said you can't tell someone
who's in agonizing pain or
life-threatening condition that they
can't pay right here on health care so
did that change more recently no in
Ireland they have you can pay private no
problem okay I like my brother he got
y'all surgery a good while back good few
years ago maybe four years ago and you
know I advised him to go private but he
decided to wait on public and he was
about he was waiting nearly a year and
didn't get anything okay so I was like
just gonna just get private man and he
got private and he got it I know within
a few months or whatever you know yeah
well not if you're stateside now you can
if you're paying private anyway in
Ireland then you can probably just get a
plan here in the United States if you're
here and get in and out pretty quickly I
mean I think we had a number was at
Bernie Sanders versus the UK those
hearts didn't see God right
in three hours here would have been
really fifty something days if he was
there in the UK I don't know exactly
Ireland you're not an America is pretty
quick yeah yeah America is pretty quick
for stuff like walk-in clinics and stuff
like that and yeah they're very they're
very flexible yeah but yeah back to my
surgery so yeah my balls then we'll
continue the ball talk on web extended
because then I want you to go but
fulfilled but continue wrap up the balls
oh yeah so basically the surgery is to
make about a 3/4 inch incision and to
take out your whole sack he'll one side
one side then they drain it I had an
infection so the tissue was pretty thick
down there and they have to cut there to
cut like the tissue and then they
wrapped it they put it back in in but
the the tissue gets wrapped around the
ball and then [ __ ] so you'll always
have like a meteor ball than the other
one that's been a stranger to speed
maybe run resolved afterwards
I don't I'm gonna just let me go to fly
over here I got extreme constipation
which is the worst pain I've ever had in
my life while having a surgery near the
groin area it was horrible and then I
didn't say this in my video so this is a
little special
she went to poop once fasted and only
blood came out I had a hemorrhoid that
burst on the inside so I only with blood
it's a that was all within the first
week of recovering it was pretty brutal
gosh
there are a lot of things that I would
describe as fine the bloody stool after
having a ball wrapped in mummy cloth is
not chief amongst them I'm fine
well I'm glad you're doing okay must be
hard to sit though like do you have to
switch the chairs right now it's fine
right now it's totally fine but yeah for
a good a good four weeks sitting was
just even standing the blood would flow
down to the area and then you'd get all
the sensations back and you could feel
inside of your testicle and like little
saggy needles you know what's that thing
that they put needles on people you know
it's like an acupuncture I'm so yeah
it's like the puncture and you're not
that's how I would describe it well you
can't get him on your balls in the
states it's against the toweling laws
and I found that one out apparently it's
not part of the spot package okay so it
is manag EULA I won't try and get it
wrong with spelled EA th ID nog like I
did da I thi what did I say think you're
mister are either I'm a little
distracted talking about bloody balls
we're gonna go to web extent again
remember everyone next week starts
Monday morning yes I will be doing some
video game streaming as well in the mug
club quarantine months what extended
coming right up stay with us
hey from mug Club happy st. Patrick's
Day can't trouble you call bebop doesn't
need to pick you up
bebop Tennessee your travels
[Music]
but I just really want
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so what happened I thought we were
talking about facts one other fact that
I wanted to share with you is about you
know Reader's Digest in the 1970s made a
point to really sensationalize the
notion of the that's really bad for
business
[Music]
that's called the gentleman died smoking
his pipe underwater oh I like that he
effectively waterboarded himself through
his meerschaum and this is an emission
pipe so people I know will be fact-check
than that just stop with the day he died
not gonna get it right dog Allah I'm not
I'm not there's no chance mr. Naugle and
I'm gonna be honest I understood maybe
20% of what he said yes and during the
WebEx interview he talks about which
video games will be streaming in the mug
Club so again the promo code is
quarantine if you join up at lattice
credit.com slash mug Club you'll get $30
off and the hashtag is mug club
quarantine all months got a lot of
credit come /schedule starting next
Monday three times a week Monday
Wednesday Friday at 10:00 a.m. Eastern
right more in the morning
live morning show chat with people on
Mudd Club and then of course the full
evening show and clips and meet segments
and listen we really appreciate how much
you guys have support us and this is not
something that occurred without
deliberation right we were sitting here
going like man well okay what are the
risks if someone here gets the corona
hmm yeah or swine flu that could combine
never know we never know the half-asian
there all the time that we end up with
some upper respiratory disease or virus
unless I'm not a doctor I don't fully
understand the difference I know that
one is bacteria and one is viral yeah
that's why you just blanket you'd be
safe you just pee you just try and play
it safe
yeah and let us know you know what it is
that you're most looking forward to by
the way we'll be live-streaming one of
these one of these days jean geek humbly
will be video games I think playing Call
of Duty with Dena glow so we'll see how
that works out and what are you most
looking forward to here this month yeah
I think I'm really excited about the
just the glut of content like that it's
more content than ever I think and also
for MO club members they'll have more
access to you they'll be able to access
as many questions as they're I did say
acts did you say act so that's my word
that's what you tried out for the NBA
just appropriate you have a
dropping soon I do yeah check it out
yeah calm
well him with a pad yeah so I think that
maybe coronavirus will take out everyone
who Shops at lids I think about it all
the time now now that that would be good
but you know just be like it'd be a yeah
yeah I think the morning shows gonna be
so much fun I think yeah less structure
it will be you know fact-checking live
fact-checking CNN people seen a lot of
other shows that we do all the time yeah
yeah they don't see because they're not
I think a lot of people don't realize if
there's like 80% more content every week
you know there's a lot of slays in Mudd
Club and Stu has a show at plays there
all kinds of people there well you have
to like every show I don't like every
show but that's the beauty of parallax
we have we have a lot of fun over there
and it's cool to be able to give that to
people that aren't in the mo Club and
they can see what it's like think - I
will sit just aggravates me so much when
I look at as a kid if I was homesick
Eimer for awhile head watch I'd watch
the funniest thing I could find on TV
and Martin's Martin Short had Morton
short board affair yeah I'm doing for me
show and you know what a daytime show is
Ward watch Martin Short yeah and watch
at one point there was a show was like
Danny Bonaduce was opposing the view and
I mean it's not you know you know I'm a
tough act to follow but anything that
was funnier yeah and then if I was sick
you know tonight I would always want to
watch Letterman when I was young and
then like Conan in the fact that these
late night hosts are just taking this
time off and broadcasting from there
like this is their moment to shine and
you know what a moment for an excuse to
just do a webcam and it would be the
people who started online this was
started my dad yeah Hopper was
effectively a producer when I was
broadcasting from my grad but instead I
I do understand this is where people
talk about connection and they think
that somehow they're serving you with
connection you know Jimmy Kimmel because
he's talking into his webcam like oh
he's just like us no they're not and you
see how terrible yeah honestly the
content the writing is like yeah I want
this also to lift the veil a little bit
for you people can do photo shops from
home people can shoot sketches from
right now we don't have 148 something
employees like they do we have it I
think right now we have eight in the
office yes usually it's 12 then we have
three remote it's down to eight just to
protection people can work from
there's no excuse for people to not be
especially because it's considered an
essential service media yeah you need to
know that people are that you're being
swindled and we're gonna do everything
we can to try and correct that yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna be exciting yeah I'm
excited to see a lot of like the the
live stream chats
that's a cool be able to interact with
you guys while we're doing the show yeah
yeah and in programming why is that
we've got like Ash Wednesday we're just
more conversational we've got mass money
mass Monday yeah a lot of people don't
know you know who actually talk about
the issues that relate to theology or
kind of culture at large in the morning
show will be fact-checking live will
have guests on here and of course some
of the stuff that we used to do in the
radio show it's a little more free flow
we'll try a whole lot of new things and
you're probably not gonna like all of it
I know I won't and one thing I want to
say this is not something you know it's
not like the Taylor Swift when she wins
her you know 29th the word like oh yeah
grabbing her face like she's Amuro
snowman after they removed after Yukon
kornelius removed his teeth that's what
I see it's just disingenuous yeah I am
really grateful I will say one thing
when I released that the kind of cell
phone video talking about this Mudd Club
quarantine a month a lot of people
commented and it's not lost on me hey
don't overdo it because we know you had
a scare with your health before when you
were over working and that is true that
has happened before but we've taken all
of that into account here and I think
we're going to be able to do it pretty
pretty well I've told everyone here that
I am going to be as regiment doing two
shows a day is not easy right radio is
typically three hours of prep for every
hour of radio I would say with this show
probably six hours of prep at least for
every single hour and then not to
mention how many dozens of hours in
pre-production so I've told everyone
like if I've got to treat this like an
athlete I've got to eat right sleep
right be discipline because I'll have to
be up like at 4:30 in the morning making
sure we get this well making sure look
at everything fact check maybe sure that
we get all of our sources together
before we do a morning show which is
fine for me because ironically for Elena
knows I'm a morning person right yeah a
morning person I don't really mornings
for them say it so I'm very and I will
be as much of a blessing I think for
everyone here to be able to because some
of us are feeling isolated like our
policy is we are only allowed in the
office and home and quarantine and
limiting social contact
not that we think any of us are going to
necessarily die from the coronavirus but
we all have parents we all have
grandparents we want to be responsible
especially at this point here on the
side of caution
so we are a little bit cooped up in
being able to have this direct contact
and communication with you guys
especially people who seem to actually
care which is remarkable to me sometimes
people bring something up and I'll see
it or someone else send it to me from
the comments section it could be about
something that has to do with hopper it
could be something that I said in a show
someone's listening to an archive from
five years ago and that's not the case
with every single host I don't think
that Jimmy Kimmel that Stephen Colbert
that Samantha bee will ever know what
that is like and that's because they
haven't been on this journey with you
it's kind of like the difference when
having you know having a dog since
they're a puppy or haven't you get to
see them grow up we came up in this
together to give you context now I've
been doing YouTube videos since 2006 or
doing political stuff in 2009 it was a
fox news PJTV when we started doing this
show so this show full-length show was
syndicated on radio the first couple
shows had like four thousand plays to
the point where I remember saying well
you know what maybe we'll just create
mug club at this point we'll just create
it and we'll just put it behind a wall
because I don't think that a long-form
show is ever gonna work on YouTube right
nobody wants to see this and then it got
the twelve thousand we have some and
then twenty seven thousand and then
millions of people each month it is
something that legitimately started from
the ground up it can not a lot of
criticisms of the show valid okay most
of them I will be chief amongst the
criticizers but the critics
that's criticize criticize there's a
word I think it's also a word but it's a
redundant work there's no need give it
days but not a valid criticism is that
it's astroturf and that's not because of
us that's because of you you have
decided and dictated how this content
moved forward and we want this month to
be an opportunity for us all to do that
to see what it is that you like to
connect with you guys maybe maybe you
want to City more long-form interviews
maybe you like us to analyze shipping
video games we don't know how it's going
to end up or where we will be at the end
of this month but we are so grateful
that we get to do it with you that
hopefully we serve you hopefully this is
helpful to you if you're cooped up at
home and then at the end of this month
will still be there with you even though
everyone else phoned it in so thank you
so much Monday morning 10:00
a.m. Eastern the great experiment begins
hashtag mug Club quarantine and please
thumbs up and leave something in the
comments section right now let people
know about it because we only survived
I don't like PBS viewers like you then
seventy five billion dollars or seventy
five million dollars in federal funding
we don't get that so it really is just
viewers like you
next week see you Monday
[Music]
you